your suspicions have been confirmed the
king of Twitter admits his social media
giant is run by a cauldron of bias we do
not look at content with regards to
political viewpoint or ideology we look
at behavior we need to constantly show
that we are not adding our own bias
which I fully admit is is left is more
left-leaning hardly surprising almost
all press has a liberal slant I know
I've worked in every kind of media and I
was always the odd man out even in those
art films I made in Germany and it's
obvious with Twitter and how they treat
the fringes fringe right your band
Fringe left have a seat in our private
lounge you can hate both whack packs and
still see Jack run to the left this
admission is key in the era of fake news
accusations what Trump's been doing is
what we've been doing for decades
sitting in front of the TV shouting at
the biased merchants at those big
networks as they delivered shoddy claims
on climate change gun control tax cuts
and God knows what else we screamed
until someone listened yep
the huge success of fair and balanced
shows that you were only getting half
the story before the half that's
imbalanced and unfair because that half
of the story is no story it's fake news
it's just what we said it was but Trump
just crunched the complaint into to
handy words instead of it being shouted
at the TV it's now coming from the TV
before the rulers of the airwaves could
mock mr. and mrs. Jones on Main Street
for their anger it's hard to do that now
that the guy in Pennsylvania Avenue has
become the Joneses spokesman so it's no
wonder new media is confessing its sins
through cables nosy neighbor they know
the jig once again is up Danny you're
hardly surprising that when he say I
gotta give him credit for admitting it
yeah well I do I give credit for a few
things he could have tweeted this yes
but instead he is not hiding in Silicon
Valley he has actually come to do
in-person interviews without it box well
maybe he will maybe who come sit with us
here at the 5:00 if you'd like that I
also thought it was interesting that he
said that there that he regrets a
decision to make Twitter about getting
more followers
and that he wishes and they're gonna try
to turn it around that it should be
about wanting to follow stories and
hashtags and issues which would have
been a very different thing interesting
in the beginning no either but at least
that they're out there thinking about it
I think that they're also doing some of
this press because there's a big hearing
on September 5th the day after Labor Day
where Twitter Facebook and Google I'll
have to be in front of the Senate Oh
that'll be fun the same day as a
Kavanagh hearings oh so every
competition well you're gonna have a
ball daily briefings gonna be hearing
mad kill me do you have any followers on
Twitter not yet no I think to three
people I might get the if this show goes
well I don't even know why you have
Twitter if you don't feel as though you
have a bigger footprint one of the
things about Twitter is not just to get
followers so you can brag on the five
and ego to actually able to say hey Greg
you're at Huntington book review come by
and you could actually say no the boy
would be better is saying I'll be at the
villages on Saturday okay I think sin
was last week you don't want to confuse
people friends buddy pretty huge we go
back to your favorite show so he admits
that his people lean to the left right
so he admits that that is playing a role
in his but they don't he said what he
says is we do not look at contact with
regards to political viewpoint or
ideology we look at behavior but without
a plan but he says he admits they have
to they they have to continue to show to
make sure there's no bias right but to
me it sounds like he can't control its
employees even if he leans to the left
but wants a fair and balanced for the
business model to work it seems he can't
control the people that are screening
out that a lot of the material location
well no one you've been in journalism
since the I remember reading you in the
eighties I mean but you have to admit
you you knew that the newsroom was
biased and it had to have some effect on
what came out on the page I guess it
does I don't think that it you know this
we can go back to the whole argument
about Peter struck you know so if you're
people it's like saying I work at Fox
most people here are conservatives do I
think it impacts our content yes but do
I think that it results
and bias from the straight news people
here I don't think so but could be I
know I leave it to you to judge well
Peter struck like a good example is a
plan to stop Trump know he didn't have a
plan he said he didn't like just
bragging to his girl I'm just telling
what the is girlfriend lover I think I
think the bigger thing with Jack Dorsey
though is is to my mind from my
perspective door sees the one guy that
said Alex Jones with all your conspiracy
theories you can hang around Facebook
YouTube Spotify they all said this guy
is about hate speech and conspiracy
theories and you should not be given a
platform Dorsey doesn't you guys say so
what if it's some of his staff they are
we just won Farrakhan we just want equal
treatment for all wack jobs yes right
friendly distributing videos from the
Islamic state of murders and beheadings
that's fine but because again this went
on and on this was YouTube this was
Facebook this was Twitter for years that
they didn't police any of that content
the issue is when we talk about Alex
Jones and all of those technology
companies all of a sudden the why now
why did they dump Alex Jones at that one
point it raises the issue of these
companies they've gotten way too big
that the government stood by
particularly with Facebook with the
acquisition of Instagram and whatsapp
they've gotten too big and they're
asking to be broken up quite frankly and
the fact that they all acted somewhat in
unison about that it smells messy I
don't actually have an opinion on this
do you think that's good for the market
like is that a good idea that these
companies be broken up that the
government step in it's but it's better
if the government looks at these
acquisitions before they happen and you
and you avoid getting a concentration of
power like this but you know and it's a
free market if conservatives don't like
the way their their speech is treatin on
Twitter on Facebook anywhere across the
internet you're welcome to media play
again can I ask you just to separate out
conservative thought from someone like
Alex Jones
I don't think Alex Jones should be
protected because you say oh it's
concern but Ellis Jones Kendall barber
Bill Maher defending Alex Jones
you have to defend the idiots all right
the whole point is the worst speech is
what you protect believe if you believe
in free speech it's tolerating the
unacceptable and put the standards of
the newspapers that we've all known -
we've all grown up with can you put that
into social media even if the most
unbiased person is trying to weed out
right and wrong and Facebook and and
everything else in Google and Twitter I
think this is one of the toughest things
possible do you think it do you think
it's a bigger issue for this guy with a
beard what's his name
jour see is that he's realizing he can't
control I think I think they're all
starting to realize that so these
earrings that they're having it's like
we have created yeah a monster the
square with the village square once we
were all connected it was supposed to be
utopia and it's been very different a
canoe opportunity to thank president
Trump for keeping his platform relevant
Twitter's problem is the fact that you
can't target the sales of laundry
detergent and pet food based on
somebody's hate of Trump yeah and that's
that's how they express themselves on
Twitter and by the way they would have
gotten rid of all those fake accounts
years ago if they really really cared
about anything but they shot him on